CONSIDERING THIS NEXT STORY.
>> IT IS.
>> I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
>>> TO THE NFC, TOM BRADY AND
GISELE BUNDCHEN APPEAR TO BE A
STEP CLOSER TO CALLING IT QUITS.
THE SEVEN TIME SUPER BOWL
CHAMPION AND HIS WIFE HAVE EACH
HIRED DIVORCE ATTORNEYS.
CHLOE, FIRST OF ALL, WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND HOW DID IT GET
HERE?
>> I'M THE BEARER OF BAD NEWS
THIS MORNING.
AND SO, LOOK, THEY WERE
TOGETHER -- THEY'VE BEEN
TOGETHER FOR 13 YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW, GISELE RECENTLY
CAME OUT IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE AND
SAID I HAVE PUT MY LIFE, CAREER,
HOPES AND DREAMS, SECOND FIDDLE
TO TOM WHILE HE HAS BEEN
PURSUING HIS NFL CAREER.
REMEMBER, HE ANNOUNCED HIS
RETIREMENT THIS PAST YEAR, CAME
BACK 40 DAYS LATER.
THEY WERE SPOTTED TOGETHER IN
EUROPE OVER THE SUMMER.
YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE BEEN SPOTTED
TOGETHER, NOT TOGETHER IN RECENT
WEEKS.
WE KNOW THEY'VE BEEN LIVING
SEPARATELY.
WE KNOW THAT SHE HAS NOT BEEN
BACK TO THE MARITAL HOME IN
TAMPA AND HE HAS BEEN SPOTTED AT
SOME OF THEIR CHILDREN'S
SPORTING GAMES, SHE'S BEEN
SPOTTED SEPARATELY WITH THE
CHILDREN.
UNFORTUNATELY IT LOOKS AS IF
MAYBE THIS MARRIAGE MIGHT BE
COMING TO AN END.
YES, THEY HAVE HIRED DIVORCE
ATTORNEYS AND A SOURCE TELLS ME
THEY ARE EXPLORING THEIR OPTIONS
RIGHT NOW.
>> ONE THING TO POINT OUT ABOUT
THEM.
THEY BOTH SEEMED TO THE PUBLIC
TO BE ATTENTIVE PARENTS OVER THE
COURSE OF THEIR MARRIAGE.
THEY SEEM OPEN TO DISCUSSING
THEIR MARRIAGE PUBLICALLY AND
THEIR RELATIONSHIP.
SO THIS MAKES IT DIFFERENT THAN
OTHER CELEBRITY RELATIONSHIPS
WE'VE SEEN.
DEBORAH, A DIVORCE -- JUST
BECAUSE THEY HIRED LAWYERS DOES
THAT MEAN THEY'RE GETTING
DIVORCED?
>> IT DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE
GETTING DIVORCED.
THEY MIGHT BE HAVING ISSUES WITH
CUSTODY SCHEDULES OR FIND OUT
WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE.
IN FLORIDA THEY USE A LAW CALLED
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION, WHICH
MEANS IN FLORIDA THEY HAVE A
50/50 SPLIT OF THEIR ASSETS THAT
ARE MARITAL ASSETS UNLESS THAT
WOULD BE INEQUITABLE.
>> THEY ARE BOTH RICH IN THEIR
OWN RIGHT.
TOM BRADY MADE ROUGHLY
$450 MILLION IN FOOTBALL.
A HUGE CONTRACT WHEN HE RETIRES.
SHE IS THE HIGHEST PAID
SUPERMODEL EVER?
DOES THAT MAKE IT EASIER?
>> DIVORCE IS NEVER EASY.
MY ADVICE IS TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
DOING, FOCUS ON THEIR CHILDREN,
WORK TOGETHER, WORK IT OUT
AMICABLY.
THEY'LL LIKELY HAVE A NEAR 50/50
SPLIT SO INSTEAD OF FIGHTING
TOOTH AND NAIL WHO HAS WHICH
ASSET, THEY SHOULD TRY TO WRAP
IT UP AND MOVE FORWARD TO THE
NEXT CHAPTER OF THEIR LIFE.
>> IT'S CLEAR FOOTBALL PLAYED A
HUGE ROLE IN THIS.
SHE WAS ELATED, THEY RELEASED
THE STATEMENTS AFTER HE SAID I
AM HANGING UP MY FOOTBALL CLEATS
AND I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
FAMILY.
HE HAS SPOKEN IN INTERVIEWS
SAYING HE HASN'T BEEN PRESENT
FOR WEDDINGS AND FUNERALS AND
BIG FAMILY MOMENTS BECAUSE OF
FOOTBALL.
BUT I HAVE PEOPLE CLOSE TO ME
SAYING HE IS THERE FOR HIS KIDS.
AFTER HE CAME BACK OUT OF
RETIREMENT, 40 DAYS LATER, THEY
WERE SPOTTED TOGETHER KISSING IN
EUROPE, HOLDING HANDS, LOOKING
HAPPY TOGETHER.
THE BIG QUESTION FOR FANS AND
PEOPLE WHO CLOSELY FOLLOW THIS
COUPLE'S EVERY MOVE IS WHAT
HAPPENED OVER THE SUMMER?
WHAT WAS THAT BREAKING POINT
MOMENT?
BECAUSE THEY LOOKED HAPPY EVEN
AFTER HE SAID I'M GOING TO GO
BACK FOR ANOTHER SEASON OF
FOOTBALL, I SAID I'M GOING TO
PLAY ONE MORE SEASON.
WHY CAN'T SHE JUST WAIT ONE MORE
SEASON IF FOOTBALL IS THE ISSUE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE DO KNOW THEY'VE HIRED
ATTORNEYS, THEY'RE EXPLORING ALL
OPTIONS.
MAYBE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO FIGURE
THIS OUT AND GET RID OF THE
LAWYERS.
>> WE KNOW HE TOOK THIS
MYSTERIOUS 11 DAYS OFF FROM
TRAINING CAMP IN AUGUST.
SO IF LAWYERS DO GET INVOLVED,
WHAT'S THE PROCESS?
>> WE KNOW THAT LAWYERS ARE
INVOLVED.
THE PROCESS WILL BE WHETHER THEY
GO INTO COURT OR NOT OR WORK
THROUGH THEIR ISSUES WITHOUT
COURT INTERVENTION, SO THEY DO
HAVE A LOT OF ASSETS AS WE KNOW.
THEY HAVE TO WORK ON DIVIDING
THEM UP.
WHO'S GOING TO GET THE MARITAL
RESIDENCE, WHO'S GOING TO GET
ANY OTHER RESIDENCES, WHAT'S
THEIR CUSTODY SCHEDULE LIKE,
PROBABLY A SPECIAL ONE SINCE
HE'S STILL PLAYING.
IT DOES TAKE A WHILE TO WORK
THROUGH.
LIKELY THEY HAVE TO DO FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURE AND GET TO CLAIM
SEPARATE ASSETS, THEIR
PRE-MARITAL ASSETS OR ANYTHING
THAT APPRECIATED FROM THAT.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF
THEM.
>> WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY HAVE